zu diesem neuen Video ein Video in dem
ich mal wieder essen bestelle ich koche
nicht rausgehen heute gehen wir es
langsam an aber natürlich nicht ganz
normal sondern gemeinsam mit Erik habe
ich das hier vorbereitet und zwar die
Randomizer 3000 Maschine wir haben hier
vorne einen Pfeil angeklebt der wenn ich
hier irgendwelche Einstellungen
vornehmen irgendwann auf einen
bestimmten Gericht landet und dieses
werde ich bestellen nicht einmal nicht
zweimal sondern dreimal deshalb legen
wir besser los seid ihr bereit für
production value unglaublich hast Du
toll gemacht Harry so wir haben hier
vorne wie gesagt das iPad steht das
erste Restaurant ist auch bereits
ausgewählt nämlich Haus Dämme dort
gibt's traditionelle deutsche Gerichte
Wirtshaus Gerichte und ein paar
exotischer Abwandlung und ich würde
sagen wir drehen am Glücksrad am Glücks
iPad einmal hoch einmal runter einmal
hoch einmal runter bisschen hoch und
runter was haben wir
ein Viertel Meter frische Bratwurst
ein Viertel Meter dicker wer gibt denn
seine bratwurstgröße in Meter lang
ich bestelle und wir sehen uns zum
Testen das Essen ist angekommen wir
haben hier den Krautsalat und die vierte
Meter Bratwurst
stimmt eigentlich ja wenn es kein
Viertel Meter ist dann
Geld zurück Garantie hoffentlich also
wenn das ein Viertel Meter ist ist
irgendwie man erwartet dass man so etwas
krankes bekommt ne 25 cm ne ja das
stimmt auch also es ist schon eine Art
und Weise ist zu verkaufen ich muss es
jetzt ausprobieren
sogar noch mehr über einen Viertel Meter
Bratwurst ich muss erstmal sagen 13,90 €
für Bratkartoffeln mit Bratwurst ist
hoch angesetzt aber das kann natürlich
auch sein frische Bratwurst der Qualität
geschuldet sein soll weil Bratwurst
kennt man ja als dieses Ding mit diesen
bratwurstläufern
Stadion und so ne das ist ja immer
richtig billig ich probiere das
Wichtigste zuerst die Bratwurst bin
gespannt weil ich so was soll besonders
sein an so einer Bratwurst
also ich fühle frische Bratwurst ich
habe mich gerade erst wieder erinnert so
frische Bratwurst hat schon diesen
charakteristischen geschmackssonne sie
schmeckt auf jeden Fall wirklich
deutlich ausgeprägter als so eine Stange
schmeckt so viel für würziger viel
herzhafter saftig auch allemal
Bratkartoffeln man sieht schon das sind
so diese klassischen ne hast du ein
Brauhaus Bratkartoffeln die oh ich weiß
nicht zu früh sein ich wollte eigentlich
nicht knusprig sein aber wir müssen den
Test machen
sie sind nicht wirklich knusprig es ist
jetzt nichts ne was mich so krass umhaut
so die die die Bestellung ist halt
wieder so ein Ding wo ich sage das ist
voll solide Krautsalat
also ich muss wirklich sagen einfach
eine unemotionale Geschichte
du bestellt Bratwurst mit Krautsalat
Bratkartoffeln du kriegst Bratwurst mit
Krautsalat und Bratkartoffeln Bratwurst
ist top Bratkartoffeln sind solide
Krautsalat zu dir ich bin so bei sieben
von zehn ja weiter geht's weiter geht's
mit der zweiten Sache ich bin gespannt
was uns erwartet wir bestellen bei einem
Laden der Chicken macht Korean Fried
Chicken das ist ja streitbarer Weise
schon so mit die krasseste Art und Weise
für Fried Chicken und wir gucken mal
rein also ich weiß dass das ein kleiner
Laden ist die werden nicht viel haben
auf der Karte deshalb gehe ich diesmal
ein bisschen langsamer rein ich streiche
immer so ich gehe mal gucken
noch nicht da und
6a frittiertes Hühnchen oh
frittiertes Hühnchen ohne Knochen
original
genau 22 Euro
dafür erwarte ich aber auch so einen
halben Kiel ein halbes Kilo Alter
[Musik]
so aussehen aber vielleicht kommen
trotzdem welche bestellen wir Runde zwei
ich habe auf jeden Fall immer noch Lust
und ich glaube das wird gut schauen wir
einmal rein der Star der Show hier drin
befinden sich mit Sicherheit unsere
chicken pieces
okay
wir behalten im Hinterkopf 22 € ist hola
aber das ist auch eine stolze Portion
also und am Ende des Tages wenn es eine
andere Qualität ist als bei anderen
Ketten so macht es auch irgendwo Sinn
Sonne guck was haben wir uns noch
gebracht sie haben uns noch okay so ein
Krautsalat mit einer Soße oben drauf
gebacken dann haben wir hier
was riecht ein bisschen
gewöhnungsbedürftig indem du meine Nase
Erik ich werde es probieren müssen hier
vorne haben wir ich habe einen Verdacht
was das sein könnte aber auch nur weil
ich mein Video darüber gemacht habe
könnte Glutamat sein also einfach so
Geschmacksverstärker
es ist schon knackig ne 22 € für so eine
Portion aber chicken hat auch eine
wunderschöne Farbe also jedes chicken
dieses gleichmäßig golden frittiert und
der Laden ist super gut bewertet ne das
kommt auch dazu gucken ob man das so
reißen kann
oh mein Gott Digger man sieht wirklich
direkt Komma und wenn ich mir das so
angucke schau du auch mal nicht aus was
sein dass so tenders also so
brustfiletstreifen sondern viel mehr so
Hähnchen Koteletts ohne Knochen so
ausgelöst und das ist ja so der
saftigste Teil von Hähnchen ich gehe mal
direkt in die Source rein und noch einen
Tipp in das würzpulver
guck mal wie Fahrzeug das ist du siehst
so richtig wie kleinteilig und wie also
ich sag ehrlich
ultra motiviert knusprig saftig also
wirklich ultra hochqualitativ man
schmeckt das direkt
brauch ich nicht drüber reden
was ich gegessen habe also keine Frage
weil wie oft hat man so richtig krass
hochqualitatives frei schicken
Salat noch probieren aber ich kann mir
eigentlich nur vorstellen dass er
komplett untergeht also weil was soll
das sein
das ist so ein Ding sagst du noch mal
ein bisschen eine andere Textur bisschen
was Frisches die Soße ist vielleicht
sogar bis zum Ketchup Mario Ding also so
Cocktail mäßig bisschen süßer aber der
Star der Show ist hier ich probiere das
hier noch mal
[Musik]
nehme zum Süßen Essig eingelegt also hat
auch wieder einen Sinn sondern es macht
geschmacklich total Sinn aber Leute
Alter
[Musik]
ich bin gespannt was hier noch irgendwie
dran anknüpfen soll das mit zehn von
zehn keine Frage ich wollte unbedingt
dass dieser Laden auch mit drin ist weil
ich habe da so oft schon selbst bestellt
aber noch nie in dem Video und es ist
jedes Mal wirklich pervers deshalb schon
mal ein dickes schaut dort an der Stelle
an Raps Barbecue das habe ich irgendwann
mal entdeckt weil es in der Nähe von
unserem alten Büro war und man kann dort
jetzt auch bestellen und es gibt
wirklich perverse Sachen Barbecue ist ja
schon im Namen aber es gibt wirklich
alles was so amerikanisch derbe ist und
ich weiß es gibt sehr viele leckere
Sachen ganz viele habe ich auch noch nie
ausprobiert und ich hoffe dass das was
ich bekomme geiles aber ich sehe die
Chancen relativ gut gucken wir mal was
uns erwartet also ihr seht es natürlich
hier unten ist wieder eingeblendet ich
gehe einmal ein bisschen nach unten weil
ich weiß es gibt hier schon ein paar
Positionen das Ding ist ich muss immer
ein bisschen aufpassen weil unten sind
die Getränke so ich kann nicht nach ganz
unten gehen weil dann kriege ich noch
Wasser
durchziehen aber wenn du weißt dann
gibt's z.B Filly cheese Steak und so ne
und dann tippen Flasche Wasser schon
etwas traurig deshalb noch mal runter
wir sind jetzt langsam aber sicher
angekommen wenn du auf einer Kategorie
stehst musst du dann alles nehmen nein
warte dann gehe ich noch ein bisschen
wir Reiter
schau mal Glück gehabt weil zwei Dinger
da drunter wäre es eine oder
81 Euro das wäre wirklich ehrenlos gehen
gib mir mal drauf oh mein Gott das ist
so eine gemischte Platte guck mal wir
haben Mac and cheese Coleslaw und so
verschiedene gegrillte ge smokete Sachen
ich werde heute Abend ne hast du gesehen
das waren allesamt wirklich teure Dinger
aber ich wollte gerade sagen für euch
mache es für mich aber jetzt vielleicht
trotzdem Spaß aber ich bestelle letzten
Sache Nummer drei ich bin schon ein
bisschen am kämpfen muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen aber was wir hier sehen
Coaster und hier drin eben diese
Zusammenstellung lässt mich doch schon
wieder ein bisschen Hunger bekommen
gucken wir einfach mal rein
Alter was sind das für Portionen guck
mal bitte hier das siehst Du jetzt schon
guck mal
Alter
Alter was oder ich es ist wirklich krank
in welchem Zeiten wir leben das sowas
geliefert werden kann
okay tschüss
gute Mac and cheese erkennbar ich habe
Sound ne ich habe es auch nach unseren
Lager voll Mac and cheese Mama gemerkt
wir müssen so unfassbar käsig saftig
sein
mich Mac and cheese ist für mich so dass
amerikanische Gericht der Kaulsdorf
hatten wir jetzt dreimal einmal Deutsch
einmal koreanisch einmal amerikanisch
und ich finde hier von allen die wir
gesehen haben ne der Vergleich das ist
auf jeden Fall der liebevollste
Krautsalat den wir bisher hatten wie
kannst du die Beilagen zuerst essen wenn
du da sowas liegen hast
Alter was habe ich jetzt was esse ich
denn erzähl die ganze Zeit weil das ist
auch das haut übertrieben rein das haut
übertrieben rein aber auch so eine
frische Art und Weise wo du aber ganz
genau weißt dass frische passiert gerade
nur in deinem Kopf weil da drin ist
Zucker da ist Mayo das ist mächtig aber
es ist trotzdem ein geiler Kontrast so
du isst das nicht wenn du jetzt
irgendwie irgendwelche Ambitionen hast
jetzt du willst dass ich diese Saint
Louis R Schneide
schätze ich 1000 Kalorien mindestens
Minimum merkt habe ich auch wirklich mit
oder komm mal bitte
[Musik]
einfach vom Knochen runterziehen
was ist das Alter was haben wir heute
für Essen hier am Start das ist so krank
dieser fleischige Geschmack ne Alter ist
das krass das grillt man oder smoked man
in Deutschland gar nicht so das ist
schon so eine ganz eigener Geschmack
chicken Drumsticks
[Musik]
ich glaube es wird nicht es wird nicht
weniger krass ich probiere hier noch mal
pulled
porkum
auch super stark wenn man sich die
gesamte Anrechnung anschaut könnte dann
bisschen mehr Soße drauf sein aber
geschmacklich und von der Textur ultra
gut man fragt sich so wo ist so die die
Sollbruchstelle wo ist der schwache Part
weil alles ist wirklich sehr sehr sehr
gut muss glaube ich auf dem gleichen
Bewertungsniveau bleiben alter das ist
krass das heftig Leute hat schon wieder
ultra gut funktioniert ihr dürft einfach
nicht normal bestellen bestellt blind
bestellt dass die Lieferanten
entscheiden lass die egal hauptsache
nicht selbst bestellen weil dann hat
irgendwie immer lacht ich würde sagen
wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video wieder
bis dahin macht's gut und ciao